[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
like a rosen bomb uh my birthday was
this past weekend i'm just gonna say it
yeah
thank you thank you i just heard a few
of you while you're driving to work or
in the house or you know in bed nude
uh say happy birthday and that um in
your head i felt it
so thank you 48 years old man
you know that whole thing where they
always say uh
you know i don't feel 48. or i don't
feel 80. i
i still got my body my body feels my
body feels like [ __ ] but my feet
i don't know what i'm trying to say is
what i'm trying to say is everybody
always says well wow how did i
get to be this age whether you're 60 or
70 and you're like i don't feel like
still and it's true i still feel like
i'm uh in my 20s man
i do i just feel like maybe if you if
you listen to me and you you
watch some of the movies i do and the
things in my instagram post you're like
well
look at you i mean you act 20. maybe
that's why you're single buddy yeah all
right everything of that
but i had a great birthday my friend
harland williams
very funny comedian dumb and dumber um
actually he did a little segment on my
patreon
uh one of my best friends in the world
we've done a lot of trips together but
uh he's got a bit he's got a pool
and a backyard and i haven't really done
anything in months and
so uh me and a few friends we all got
tested before and we all spread out in
his yard and
and swam and uh
it was great man it was great i was uh
it was exciting i felt you know you know
there's six people there i just felt
like hey
or and i got a lot of nice gifts too
look at this hold on
i got this this is uh inside you pillow
pillow that's a pillow lea and kristen
got it for me it has all the names
of everybody that's been on the podcast
inside of you look at that
it's pretty incredible i really love
that gift they sent me a nice
and i always say hey don't get me
anything i really have everything i want
just um you know
some you know i have good friends and
you know you guys out there it's enough
you know and um but when you get
something it's still
you know i'm not gonna like especially
when it's a good gift you're like holy
crap this is uh i'm glad they decided to
get me
no they didn't have to get me anything
these uh you know
and just to talk about patreon for a
second
you know all my listeners uh those that
really love the podcast
extra and they want extra footage and
supporting the podcast
these folks there's like 550 of them
that are just amazing and uh
you know it's a great it's a great thing
it's a great community but
uh they're so giving they're so loving
and um
you can't help but i i feel like it's
not just uh
oh this is a patreon and fans can go
watch stuff i feel like it is a
um it's something special for me and
especially during this hokovid time this
whole virus thing and all
it just it's just like i feel like
i have something more to do and um
and i know i just love the podcast and
some some good stuff coming your way
i can't tell you right now but uh some
good stuff
could be potentially great stuff um also
for the podcast before we get to the
guest dog
i get new mugs they'll be on on the
inside of you store
shortly but uh they're different color
and uh inside of you
cool mugs look at that boom boom inside
thank you for allowing me to be inside
of you
limited supply and of course we got the
uh the masks
this is the face mask say inside you
with michael rosenbaum so that's
kind of nice kind of neat you can get
those on the inside of your online store
at the end of this we'll uh i'll read a
fan uh letter like i
try to always do we'll read uh give my
patrons some shout outs
uh the other patreon too where have all
the good horror movies gone with john
heater and michael rosenbaum you can
look at that
a lot of fun we do zooms and all that
stuff anyway
you know and also shout out to my uh
good buddy preston preston christensen
he turned 15 on july 8th i hope he got
his presents by now
um bought him a bunch of cool stuff we
both love jim crotche that's all i'll
say
the singer you know i have to say i love
you in a song
uh but he's been he's had eight
surgeries for cancer he's 15 years old
and he has uh
he's been through so many radiation and
chemo treatments and uh i love him he's
like a little brother to me
and i've become a family member of this
family michelle and chris and chandler
and renee and
uh you know thanks to lisa fox for 104.3
fm in la for giving preston a shout out
and uh nico for putting him in his
little video game the bionic kid that
you can get the app for
he put preston a character of preston
it's just nice i i definitely when i do
things for other people
i feel better about myself i feel better
i just it makes me feel
full you know or just i don't know
better i guess
lack of a better word better it's
amazing how you hear
gratitude can do so much and i'm telling
you about experience
you know when before i go to bed i think
i've said this but you know i i closed
my eyes and
those nights that i remember to do so i
close my eyes and think of things that
i'm grateful for
i get an image of my grandfather an
image of my grandmother an image of
whatever it is preston um
and i uh if if i happen to fall asleep
which i do
my dreams are better i sleep better i'm
going into bed with a healthy
mind i guess i call it cheesy whatever i
mean you've been with me for a year and
a half so i think you're you're here
you're not going anywhere i hope let's
get into it um you know this guy has
been around
uh i say that in a very um
admirable way he's very intelligent went
to a prestigious school
but uh he seems like one of the guys
he's uh
very an intense actor somebody who uh
has done a lot of work has appeared
naked on
um on stage i don't know if i could do
that
i'd probably have to stretch it out if
you know what i mean
but you know him from buffy the vampire
slayer and angel
and he's just done a ton of stuff he's a
great guy and we had a really good
conversation he got very personal and i
hope you enjoy this this is
goes out to a lot of the patrons who
recommended him i always try to
listen to your comments on patreon and
the guests you want i do my best to get
them
um and great guests on the horizon too i
can't wait to
share with you all right let's get into
james marsders
it's my point of view you're listening
to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
where are you right now where you're at
your house but where do you where are
you at where do you live
i'm in los angeles sunny los angeles
uh in uh and that's where i am
have you lived at this house for a while
yeah i um
i've lived here for
about 17 years uh i was living in
santa monica uh and i had a
little tiny uh one bedroom and a four
plex
uh i was on just getting off of buffy
and angel and uh and it saves all my
money
and then you lived in an apartment and
then you saved all your money from buffy
and angel
which was probably a decent amount of
money yes it was
by the end of it yeah because it was six
years so there's a good amount of money
and um then i took my nissan
to raise her and i needed a house good
school system
and a nanny like i needed a four bedroom
freaking house
and uh i
i did so i went and got one and got a
house uh
in a neighborhood with a good public
school system and
and the money just went like gone just
well uh yeah
the money that i'd saved you know uh and
i had to figure out how to how to
make house payments and and uh keep keep
the lights on without being on
a regular on a tv show now you've been
working uh but i did
i mean you've been working like crazy i
read all this stuff you know i do a
little bit of research not much because
i just like to shoot the [ __ ] and find
out what makes people tick and what
adversity they face and all the stuff
that and how they keep going and i find
that stuff more fascinating which i
like to tell my guests but it's not that
i don't care about your career and
you've had a big crew and you have a
huge fan
fandom you know buffy and angel you've
produced or been in a part of 70 plays
or
many many plays you went to juilliard
for a couple years you did all these
things
uh and it's pretty amazing but the first
thing you said
and you started it was i had to raise my
niece
yeah so how does that happen the hardest
thing i've ever done in my life well why
did this happen
uh my brother couldn't get it done
you know uh my little brother uh is a
dual diagnosis
and uh he's a good man but he uh
was not able to to take care of her and
he asked me to
uh and she was five and a half and how
old were you
40 you want to say yeah 40.
i mean that's not an easy thing to sort
of uh
i mean i mean your first answer probably
is uh
uh wait let's think of some options here
uh
what i mean i mean your response
certainly wasn't absolutely amen
uh it kind of was
really uh yeah um
well i mean that's it's
for for i don't know my
like like for a lot of families and
uncles stepping in and raising
a nephew or a niece is not really
abnormal
it's not you know it is a big ask
definitely
but it's not that weird
you know uh maybe it would be maybe it's
weird for a hollywood actor to say yes
yeah i have to say um honestly with all
sincerity i think if
my brother said hey you know i'm gonna
have to ask you
uh to take care of uh my daughter let's
say
no that's not gonna happen uh
i'll i'll uh i don't know what i would
say i mean look to be honest i mean you
know you don't know what you do until
you're
in that situation and then you sort of
go okay wait a minute wait a minute
am i the best person for this job
because i look at myself like dude come
on man you live alone you're like
you know when you take care of something
you got two dogs did you were you
worried could you do this
yeah well that was the first thing is is
that i was the only one in the family
that was willing
everyone else said no so and then the
second thing i i guess i was the last
one asked
um but uh yeah so the initial ask was
no one else is wrong so it's either you
or she's going to go into a foster home
and i know enough about little girls in
in
foster care to know that that really
wasn't
uh going to be a good outcome for my
niece well she's lined up she's my
daughter now
um uh
and yeah i was i was i was crazy worried
man um
i was already a father uh but i was a
weekend father
and uh we would shoot we would shoot
buffy we shot
about 70 80 hours a week and then i
would get in a car on friday night or
early saturday morning and then drive
350 miles to go to go visit my son which
is like a whole nother
adventure uh and then spend the weekend
with him every other week
and come back and and keep shooting uh
right so i had i had experience being a
parent um
but that is the the difference between
being
the good time weekend dad and being the
one
the the dad who's going to be enforcing
structure
uh is just a is a night day
hey wait a minute you're uh you're you
know you're glitching you're talking and
i'm seeing your mouth
but it's like glitching a little bit let
me see now start talking
please be good please be good oh
that's i think oh yeah bro
i think we have what we call some people
and i think that my skin texture
also looks oh yeah phenomenal so
yeah okay this is good that's good we're
good now we're good
yeah all right so we were talking about
my wife again thank you
mrs marsders is that her last name
what was her name before uh it was um
ramen
ramen yeah she's uh she is half
bangladeshi
and half german oh does she speak german
she does
does she ever speak to you like splendid
oh yeah all the time she sings in german
does she say hi it's mao i mean shut up
shut your mouth i i don't remember
shut your mouth james enough with your
buffy [ __ ]
no one wants to hear this anymore i'm
tired
news it's old he has no discernible
accent whatsoever
really yeah i kind of like a little
german accent
i don't know i've been out with a german
one before i always liked the accent
though
michael you have to slow down you talk
too fast
i'm like i know i'm sorry no she knows
since some ways she knows english better
than i do
uh she'll she'll be able to spell a word
that i don't know or there's some some
in some situations punctuation that
escapes me i'll go and ask her about
it and uh and she'll know things i don't
know yeah that's usually the case for me
i never know anything that's right when
it comes to english i never say the
right thing i never do the right thing i
never spelled the right thing we're
americans we were not really educated
really
and not as well not as well that's just
what are we gonna do
all right so all right so you take on
your niece who becomes your daughter and
what's her name
uh you know i i'm a little the one thing
that my
my my daughter has asked me is to keep
her out of uh
social she does not
want any reflected celebrity
whatsoever uh she's really clear about
that good for her
that she doesn't want to be an actor
though right she doesn't want to be an
actress
well there you go she's a mathematician
she's going for her doctorate
yeah mathematics and uh for now she's
closing in on her master's right now
see this is see i'm bragging again which
is me i'm talking about her
um she's an amazing person she's she's
my phoenix and she uh
uh yeah
did you did you get good grades growing
up were you smart did you excel in math
and
literature and all these things in high
school were you a smart guy
you see because you're a smart guy so
obviously yeah i don't know you know
mike
i grew up in a highly intelligent family
and i came i
came to understand at least in my family
that intelligence more often than not
was just
used to rationalize insanity
or ill behavior and that that it
that high intelligence often is just
people spinning their wheels in the mud
um and so yeah i uh
that says so much to me intelligent i
would yeah i guess i would say that i'm
intelligent i don't know
how good that is really i really like
the way you said that though you almost
said like really intelligent people it's
like almost like
it's a cover for almost like they have
ill intentions in
a way like where they can get away with
bad things because they
appear to be so knowledgeable or you
know is that just yeah or just
to myself you know i have a i have a
capacity to
to rationalize uh myself to myself
and and tell myself that i'm doing doing
the right thing when in fact i'm not
uh and and so that my intelligence is
actually a tool
for me to deceive myself and i notice
that in other intelligent people too
um don't you dare look at me and say
that
no i was just thinking you know i did i
did a play where this guy
uh was pretending to be
uh a person
[Music]
someone with a very low intelligence
very low intelligence he was a murderer
who was
trying to get away with it in this way
or hide and kill people it was a play
and so i i went and hung out with a
community of people
uh of very low intelligence and
they were supremely happy good people
it was it was absolute joy to be around
them i felt good every time i was around
them
uh whereas i mean when i hang out with
you i got to say i'm i i am
very happy you're a great guy there you
go see it
correct me if i'm wrong but often times
when you when you were talking with
someone who's very intelligent
especially someone
who's very intelligent and is very proud
of that or
really taking themselves seriously or
trying to prove how intelligent they are
it's really annoying you know i remember
i mean she's not listening to this
anyway but i remember being at carrie
fisher's party not to name drop
years ago and she had a couple of drinks
maybe but i remember
sharon stone going on and on
about how high her iq was and i thought
my friends would punch me in the face if
i said that once she's like oh i have a
very very high iq
my iq is extremely high i'm like
wow you're brilliant yeah i just sat
there going
wow she's really saying this out loud
and a couple of us were looking at each
other like
wow but you know um
you said really no go ahead
really intelligent people have the
capacity to explain
things that might seem complex in a very
simple way
if like the kind of intelligence that i
really respect like um
i remember oh what's his name mccully
uh is this older actor in chicago
explained uh
hamlet to me and hamlet had always been
this this uh
you know great play with big themes and
all this complexity
and he was just like no it's just about
a teenager who's who's wondering if he
should kill himself because he finally
realizes the world is totally messed up
that's it that's the whole thing you
know
does he do does does hamlet give up
uh or does he try to change things does
he try to make a difference or does he
just
once he really learns how infinitely
screwed up his
his surrounding world is does he just
kill himself or give up or does he try
to affect positive change and that's it
uh this is stunned you know but it took
someone of very high intelligence to
kind of
um to bring that to be able to pare it
down to
it's simple truth i wish people would do
that i wish instructions like
instruction manuals for like fixing a
lamp or things like i wish they would
just say in one sentence
this is all you have to do i start
looking at things and i just get
overwhelmed by everything everything
overwhelms me i don't like reading
directions i just try to wing it
you seem like a direction guy you look
at the directions you study them
i have been that in the past
and i gotta say i'm a little a little
bit better now like i got
i got a bowflex and i got that thing in
the mail
and that was just like oh i'm i'm
screwed like this thing
i'm never and and the thing about a
bowflex is if you do it wrong it's all
about tension and wires and stuff and
you're likely to just
slice open your choroid artery but you
figure that out
i was well motivated to like really pay
attention to step one
make sure step one's done and move on to
step two
and that that went well do you think do
you think you were um
i mean obviously we evolved so and you
mature but
mature do you think like in when you
start you started to do plays in like
how old were you when you started doing
uh you got into acting uh fourth grade
fourth grade
first fourth or fifth grade foursquare
and you knew or people looking at you
like no he's got something this guy's
good
i don't know it was i played eeyore i
remember in winnie the pooh
and i remember being really like
passionate about getting to the pathos
of eeyore like i really thought that
there was a sadness
and a depth to that character that i
wanted to mine so i i suspected i was a
little too serious
for the play uh so maybe but i think
then in sixth in the summer between
sixth and seventh grade i did
two plays and then i was truly bit
and i remember one was called the me
that nobody knows
which was a a musical
written by inner city kids
uh whether the monologues were written
by inner city kids and then
uh broadway people wrote songs based on
the things that they that they wrote
uh and i just remember singing in front
of an audience and
feeling connected to them uh
and feeling like i was doing a good job
uh
and that everyone was kind of good with
it like we were all together in the same
room i was doing this thing they were
looking at me and everybody no one was
uncomfortable and it was all
kind of good and i remember being really
bit by that did your parents
sort of uh tell you hey james or jimmy
jimmy you're really good to me did they
call you jack um
no okay no not so much uh
i wouldn't say like the best thing that
that i got from my parents was complete
apathy toward
whether or not i should be an actor like
they just didn't really didn't care like
it's up to you you know do what you want
they weren't really against it they
weren't really that forward either so
you didn't have to really you didn't try
to try to prove to them that you were
good that you always
were always trying to like look at me
i'm great were you that guy were you
that kid that was just like i want
everyone to know i'm great because look
i think i did i think i have
many times in my life i'm like i want i
want to be great so people think
and that's obviously not the way to be
yeah i
definitely was like that there was a
time when i thought that if i couldn't
be the greatest actor in the world there
was no point in trying
at all and and then then you you come to
realize that
that there's no real competition in art
you know that all artists we're all
trying to just
uh get honest with ourselves and express
what we find
so like um like i could
i you would never want to do
uh rebel without a cause like the remake
if you get the call we're remaking rebel
without a cause you want the lead
you know you would never say yes to that
because you cannot
touch james dean and you can't
no success will be in in redoing that
but i don't know if james dean would
make the greatest spike
frankly exactly so i i'm only trying to
be the best
me uh and so in that way there's no
competition at all
uh and i suspect the same would be true
with the other arts you know sculpture
you know you can't you know
if you have to ask a sculptor you know
who's better
michelangelo or rodan you know be like
well they were trying for different
things there were different people
expressing different things so i mean
like i don't know see
we get we get into that too and i've
gotten to this on the past podcast where
then you start comparing yourself like
oh because i would do that i go i love
music so much i love music more than
anything in the world i'm not
the most amazing singer i'm not the most
amazing musician but i love it i love
it i'm like but i shouldn't do it
because you know uh so-and-so has such a
great voice and my voice isn't even on
unless
i shouldn't do it and that's not why you
should do things
and it's taken me so long to understand
that
if you just enjoy it you can't you the
whole world isn't going to love what you
do no matter what
just do it because you love it because
if you're not doing what you love
then i i don't even know why you're here
on this planet so
and i've been on this planet a long time
so far and i well it's short time if you
think about it but
i feel like i don't want it to get too
late in life where i
i miss out on things because i'm scared
or uh
i don't feel like you know i'm gonna be
great at that or
i just want to try to enjoy things and
did you
have you always enjoyed acting have you
always yeah
you know i i primarily enjoyed being
in a group of people that were
functioning more or less harmoniously
you know uh
[Music]
that was i think that and then that's
the sense of connection
of being on stage
uh you got a message
no i'm just thinking like
like i think that i think for me art
is an is an artist
creating something that expresses their
experience
and then they put the art out into the
world to see
does anyone else react to this am i
alone
you know and then if the audience reacts
to it or if the public reacts to it
and the public says wow i recognize
myself in that piece whether it's
painting or
or a tv show or whatever then the
artists who made it
feel more connected like oh i'm not
alone
um and the great thing about theater is
that moment
happens when you're in the same room
with the audience so you can see it
happening
and and it's powerful for the audience
too because the audience
is if everything's working right the
audience is looking at the play going oh
i felt that i'm not alone
um and then they see the other audience
members
react to it and so they're not alone in
the fact that
the other they're with a group of people
who feel the same way or a similar way
and there's this wonderful sense of
connection that starts to grow
when a play is working the opposite is
true when a play is not working oh yeah
this pretentious piece of [ __ ] i
remember i went to see it
i'm not gonna even get into i remember i
saw well i saw a play with a friend and
we were going to see a friend but
what are the odds of the person who's in
the play's best
friend or brother sitting right next to
me
oh no no so i just you know i didn't say
anything but i was just like
no play needs to be for i'm not look i'm
not like i just
if a movie's more than two hours i'm
usually out unless it's forrest gump i'm
just i'm not into it
if it plays more than three hours [ __ ]
off
if a concert's more than three hours
[ __ ] off
i just i don't have the patience for it
and i remember just going
oh my we have how could we have do we
have three intermissions
right i've never heard of that has that
has that ever happened i think he heard
some of that and then i
and then when i went you know i might
have caught a nap like a little doze
and then i remember backstage he was
like right there with me and i go
oh my god oh my god it's like hey this
is michael i'm like
dude i think i'm an idiot and i know he
said something it just i can do one
better
i uh remember going to see
again in chicago the this uh this actor
director in town
uh had directed me in a really wonderful
play and i was hoping that he would use
me again
he's a really good director and he was
acting in a play and
i went to see it and the play really
wasn't that good he was at a good
performance
and i thought that i owed him my honesty
when i went backstage so i told him
that he was in a dog and and and to see
his face just
just fall uh was once did he ever talk
to you again
no yeah that could ruin a friendship
you know because he's got to go out
there and hump that thing over the hill
every night oh yeah you made a mistake
james
you can't that way you can't you can't
rob somebody maybe the last night you
say hey by the way you're done this is
it right you're not doing it
they're not extending the play right
yeah you're sure yeah
oh man this is a dog brah i did one play
it was it was uh the marriage of figaro
not the
not the not the opera but the play and
um it's a it's comedy right it's a it's
a biting comedy about
uh about uh class and
uh it was misdirected and
uh we didn't get one laugh
in a month and a half just absolute
crickets not
one laugh and about two weeks into the
run
it got to be kind of a relief to realize
how bad the play was that we were doing
and and just revel in
uh how bad it was i guess that's all you
can do you gotta hey what your survival
tactic
is hey this is what we're doing let's
just bear down and
you know [ __ ] do it but you know
we have to do the plays directed so
we're just going to do this thing but
yeah you know i read that you were in a
play and they rolled you out on a wheel
and you were naked
that was my my professional debut yeah
and where was that
that was at the goodman theater in
chicago how old were you
24. i think and this is
all naked but this is penis balls
everything yeah
oh yeah the um the artistic director was
a
was like the goodman was the big premier
theater
in chicago it had a much older audience
subscription base
um and they had just hired a new fiery
young artistic director
and he wanted to kick out he wanted he
wanted to get a younger subscription
base so he wanted all the old people to
get offended
and so that he could have room to
attract a younger audience and he could
do edgier plays
and so he put nudity in every in every
show in that first season
and uh did younger people come out to
see you because you
you they heard dong was in it did you
hear that did you hear that long duck
dongs in this play i'm gonna go check
out that play
where did you get more were there more
women or more guys or whatever they came
to see the show because
i could hear i could hear the clicking
of the opera glasses it was a big house
and and they would roll me out and i'd
go out here
never was like with their little you
know binoculars their little
monocle what are they called no they're
like they they're really old-fashioned
oh yeah yeah yeah little flick out and
then it's blind
it's a little tiny pair of binoculars
but i remember the um
the sprites the the the guys who were
playing the little fairies and sprites
who were wheeling me out
would show me pornography because i was
strapped in the thing
so they would like shove pornography in
front of me right before they they uh
they rolled up to try and get you
aroused yeah yeah yeah yeah did it work
no hell no no how good you're about to
be rolled out in front of 700 people
like there's nobody well wait a minute
when
you say rolled are you rolled upside
down and up rolled upside down no no no
it was like on a
because the flippity flap i was kept
thinking if this is a wheel that's going
like that
around it's going to flap it's going to
be too funny
people are going to be like oh there's
this dick flapping up and down up and
down
thank god so did you let me ask you this
because i would do this
did you stretch it at first like hey i
don't want it to be too cold or i want
to
i want to pull it down i want to make it
longer than it is
you had to i wish i would have thought
of that or maybe you're just
fine i didn't didn't i know i didn't try
but you were quoted as saying after that
i could be naked anywhere it didn't
matter at that point
after doing that yeah i mean that that
that got
you know you know you'll survive after
doing that i don't know that i would say
that i
i it has no effect on me you know
i don't know i don't know that i am
entirely comfortable
i guess if it's for a good cause like i
did this play called just friends
where it was just it was it was a picnic
during world war
ii apparently um during world war ii
people would go
out into the fields and watch the german
bombers come over
on their way to london and they would
actually picnic and watch this
and it was a a man
who was discovering that he was gay
meeting a
openly gay artist and them sitting down
and having a talk and a picnic together
and at the end of the play the artist
that i play the artist
takes off all his clothes and
there's a pause and the gay the the man
who's discovering himself
takes off all his clothes and then they
lay down to sunbathe
and it's lights out and it's just called
just friends
like they're not going to become lovers
they're just they're just there for each
other as human beings they're just
talking about them
and so and it's really cool and in that
way i was
uh happy to do the nudity you know
that it served like a real purpose there
um
if the nudity is just for titillation
i'm a lot less comfortable
yeah inside of you is brought to you by
better help online counseling i love
these guys
i talk about it all the time but i you
know i deal with anxiety
constantly and depression it runs in the
family and
uh you know if you don't talk about it
it gets you
it just gets you no matter what you
think all of a sudden one day you're
like why am i anxious
and you want to keep it in check man
guys you want to keep it in control and
better help
online counseling these are the guys
that can help you
better help online counseling
extraordinary times we're living in
struggling with uh stress and anxiety
depression everything um
betterhelp offers online licensed
professional
counselors who are trained to listen and
help and they specialize in many areas
including like i said uh
you know stress relationship conflict
anxiety depression
loss trauma more securely connect with
your counselor in a safe and private
online environment everything you share
is confidential
you just fill out a questionnaire i mean
this is easy i'm lazy
fill out a questionnaire to help assess
your needs and
get matched with the counselor within 48
hours easily schedule secure videos or
phone sessions with your therapist
plus exchange unlimited messages and if
for any reason you're unhappy with your
counselor
you just you request a new one no charge
you can get professional help when you
want
wherever you want better help is an
affordable option and our listeners get
off your first month with the discount
code inside
join over one million people taking
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional
uh they're recruiting additional
counselors now in all 50 states because
so many people been using better help so
that's how good they are
so so if you need a therapist i mean
good lord get started today at
betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp.com
inside talk to a therapist online
and get help let me ask you did your
life completely
change when uh when you got buffy
that that that was that the sort of the
turning point of like
okay this is the next level people are
have you ever really been recognized
as much or or was it really buffy that
did that oh it was absolutely buffy it
was a night and day i mean like i would
get
i would get like when you're doing
theater um you might have someone stop
you ended up taking a walk and someone
would stop you and say
i saw you you met beth last night you
were very nice or you know
there would be that thing kind of going
on but that was night and day from
the kind of thing that happened during
buffy uh
and i was uh i was afraid of being
famous i was terrified that i would lose
my soul and become a douchebag
if i got famous uh i i uh
i did this man we're talking so much
about theater but it's formative for me
so
so um were you part of the thespian
society in high school
no i did a play in high school i was in
i took drama for four years then i did a
play
and then when i went to college i
started doing more and more plays and
got it yeah yeah
there's a the drama club you know the
nationwide drama club
lesbian society right so um every other
year
they would go to ball state university
and have a convention
and for that convention they would they
would have a play that was cast
from all around the country um and my
senior year
was coincided with uh with this
convention and that
year's play was god's spell and they
cast me as jesus in the in the play
and within the confines of ball state
university
we were like the who in 1972.
we we were we were like led zeppelin in
70 you know
um and like we had to we had to have
bodyguards we had to be shuttled around
we had people like breaking into our
into our
uh dorm room the thespian club the
thespian society
is this yeah yeah yeah it was this weird
thing and and like after the play the
audience like stormed the stage and they
started
tearing my costume off you know trying
to get bits of the costume
yeah and i remember thinking like i'm
really glad this is happening to me
at age 18 because now i know i don't
want to go to hollywood
i i i this is not what i want
so i will stay in theater where it's
it's not you know being super famous
is not usually in the cards i would have
ran
i would have just like yes take me away
calgon
this is awesome and then of course you
figure it out
yeah so you experienced that but like
well first of all i want to go back
because i know you told this story but i
i like to twist it up a little bit if
possible
so when you get buffy is it something
like you obviously auditioned for it
yeah and you didn't do they want english
accent they did they asked me if
uh i could do any other accents i said
yeah i can do quite a lot of different
accents and they said you'll give us
another one
and um and i i had
again i had done a play where i i used
uh
uh i let's see um
like a deep's uh like a louisiana accent
like deep
deep on south way on down louisiana like
that
and again i was playing a killer and the
killer was on the phone with the lead of
the play
and we were getting all of these laughs
that that we didn't plan on
having and i remember asking the
director why are we getting these laughs
and they
said well they can't see your face and
you're using that accent they think
you're black so
it's playing differently than i wrote it
but it's actually working very well
and i was like okay um and i thought
when they asked me later
during the buffy audition like what
other accent i thought well
because he said he said that the accent
that you're using
would have been a white accent say 150
years ago but in modern times it's only
it's only only black people would use
that accent now so they think you're
black so
i thought wow a vampire that would be a
fun accent
to use that to use that one i'm a
vampire so i did that as well but i mean
like
joss wanted to uh joss whedon the guy
who did buffy uh who made it up
um he wanted a an english punk rock
vampire
and uh it's not surprising that he said
no that's cute
that other accent's very cute but i want
what i want what did you wear
for the audition uh i imagine the the
character
was really scruffy so i wore this old
black
t-shirt um that
i'd had for like 15 years most of my
clothes at this point i was really poor
so most of the clothes i had i
had had for 15 years but this black
t-shirt you know like have you ever had
one of those t-shirts that you wash it
so often that all the
cotton is gone yes and from the blend
and you only have the
synthetic stuff behind you know um
because that was the most messed up
t-shirt that i had that wasn't full of
holes
and they loved that t-shirt and in fact
they used that t-shirt for the first few
episodes maybe the maybe all of season
two we used that t-shirt
and what had been like a dish rag in my
life
suddenly became actually the shroud
because they couldn't double it they
couldn't find a t-shirt that was that
messed up
so there's only one of them so that
whenever i had that whenever i was in
costume they're like
be careful you're drinking coffee don't
get it on the t-shirt because of the
t-shirt
did you know in the room when you're
reading for josh you read for jaws
obviously
yeah exhaust and a whole bunch whole
bunch of people did you
did you really milk it did you turn it
on with that accent
because that accident surprisingly i
know you've heard it but it's like most
people think you're english
and then they meet you and they're like
holy [ __ ] he's not i think the accent
was not actually that great
in the first bit uh i think it got
better
uh as time like if you do anything for
six years you'll probably get pretty
good at it
you know and i think by the end of it it
was really a credible accident but in
the beginning
wasn't that great but i thought it was
great and yes i i was
i was uh i remember
this is this is great i remember being
so proud that i
was from theater and that i thought that
i had much more experience than anyone
else auditioning so i remember being out
in the audition room
and facing a wall doing shakespeare
monologues really loudly just so
everyone else would think
uh oh that's a real actor i'm screwed i
was trying to mess with people not
realizing
nobody cares about shakespeare in los
angeles
did they hate him the people in the
audition room they thought i was
psychotic
i imagine it is called the evil a most
miraculous work of this good king
since my hero in england i have seen him
do
i mean like what the [ __ ] is he doing
he's on buffy and then finding out that
that
that insane man got the role you just
like i quit
forget it you know you know and you hear
about this because i i'm one that could
relate to you about the you know the
hair and the bleach and i had to shave
my head so we could relate to it and
so but like it it burned it really
burned your scalp like it hurt oh so bad
so bad yeah but it because it was just
because
we had to do it every episode we had to
do it every
every eight days because a vampire's
dead so your
the hair doesn't grow so you can't have
roots so
on the bottle it says only do this every
six weeks it's not safe to do it more
often than that we were doing it every
eight days so
when you when you when you bleach you
would get blisters you get blisters on
your skull
uh because it's really heavy chemical um
and so we were we were pouring bleach on
top of the open wounds from the last
bleaching like
every eight days did you think that you
were gonna maybe not grow your hair out
like you're gonna lose your hair you're
gonna go bald you're gonna be scarred
for life
yeah they would say we don't know if
you're gonna have hair by the end of
this and i was like
screw it pay me i'll buy hair you know
like after after
after 15 years of abject poverty i you
know the hair was my last concern
wow i was just trying to make money to
because i became a father so i moved
down to los angeles to try to buy
diapers and health care and stuff like
that and so you know at that point
hair schmer schmer but you know i didn't
know i don't know how to do anything
else and you know like keep paying me
i'll do
jesus i mean you're acting you're doing
something you love you know the
character wasn't supposed to be around
very long and then
you know they the fans loved you did you
feel like
uh i'm gonna renegotiate and they're not
gonna pay me this guest rate [ __ ]
and i'm gonna get paid salary and i'm
gonna get paid fairly because i'm an
integral part of this mofo show
uh no i i um i was only signed to one
year
and the whole idea was they told me you
would be in between five and ten
episodes and so my whole deal was just
to try to make it closer to ten than
five
that was the whole thing and then and
then at the end of season two on buffy
but the job was over
and i do remember thinking try to do it
without me
guys i'd rock and then i remember tuning
in to season three which i wasn't in
uh at the time and they had a character
called faith
that eliza deski was doing and that was
freaking awesome
and i remember thinking oh my god they
don't need me at all but they did
i don't know i uh think that it was a
character that the writers enjoyed
exploring
you guys got along real well you and
joss no i was terrified of jaws
really absolutely i've never met him but
he i thought you know i thought he was
just
such a nice guy gentleman right yeah but
the thing the thing is is that um
uh i was imperiling the theme of buffy
which is
that buffy is actually the same theme as
hamlet which is how do you get
through adolescence how do you see the
world is screwed up and not give up how
do you take
arms against the sea of troubles how do
you how do you make a positive
difference in the world
and um vampires in buffy are just
metaphors for
all of all of the challenges that you
face in that period
um and so uh you know joss felt the
vampire should be ugly
they should be very quickly overcome and
they were not supposed to be sexy
he he said i don't like that anne rice
crap and
he got talked into one romantic interest
vampire that was angel it wasn't his
idea uh
and he that was the only one that was
the exception
and then i came along and i wasn't
designed to be a romantic character but
then the audience
reacted that way to it and i remember he
backed me up against a wall one day and
he was just like
i don't care how popular you are kid
you're dead you hear me you're dead
dead and i and i i was just like uh
you know it's your football man like
okay you know wait was he was he kidding
around
no hell no hell no he was angry with you
he was angry at the situation i think or
he was did he ever apologize
no he why should he if it had been me in
his shoes i'd have killed me off
just immediately so wait wait wait
you're saying he resented you because of
your popularity
he resented a situation where he had to
deal with another romantic
vampire when his theme was that vampires
are the problems you get
you have to get over in high school in
season two
when the when the when he's trying to
hold on to a really good theme
and it's getting corrupted by by
by surprise character right and and i
like evil is not cool
you know evil and i think that a lot of
a lot of uh what we do in the hell in in
los angeles and hollywood
like when we portray evil is cool i
think that we're really lying
i think that evil is stupid and
laughable
and and um it should not be portrayed as
cool and i really respect joss
that he is not interested in portraying
evil as cool
uh and yeah i mean if if i had been
producing that show
and and i had been in control and spike
was getting
a romantic thing i i just would have
slit his throat right away
that's right we just protect the theme
yeah what's your because
i don't think i'm as brave as josh josh
decided to like
deal with it you know and try to try to
find a way to
to explore that who did you love working
with most like if you remember like off
the cuff like right on top of your head
who tony had anthony had played giles
the older guy
um he was hands down the best actor on
the show
uh he uh
i remember i did my first scene with him
and i remember thinking
oh man would you wake up i'm gonna mop
the floor with you man
because he wasn't doing anything he was
kind of mumbling
and i didn't catch it and then i saw the
episode and he just
there was no need to watch me it was all
about him
because he wasn't lying he wasn't
performing he wasn't trying to impress
anybody
he was just letting you stare at him as
he figured stuff out
it was fascinating and i remember
realizing
that i had to go back to zero and i had
come in
so proud of of all of my tools from
stage
and very few of them were going to be
useful in front of the camera
and so i i uh i would watch tony and i
would
i would come in even if i wasn't in the
scene i would just sit on an app box and
watch him work
and notice what he was doing and most
importantly what he was not doing
he was not pushing it out he was just
experiencing something
that the camera could document he was
giving himself an actual experience
that the camera could then record do you
have a strong work ethic do you um
are you hard on yourself do you learn
lines easily do you
uh do you get nervous on set do you uh
let things kind of overwhelm you
do you is there that kind of essence
that you sort of carry
on on around when you're working i don't
know if i get nervous
no i don't get nervous in fact when when
things go really wrong on set
i love that because then i get a chance
to show off
you know like uh like we have to get
this shot we're out of time
you know i love that uh really
yeah yeah you want to be the go-to guy
yeah because i
mean i know my lines man i'm like okay
okay let's jump off the cliff we have to
do it this is exciting you know
um but i've learned that in order to
have fun
i have to know my lines really well
because if i don't know my line so well
then i'm sweating it and and then it's
very stressful
but if i know my lines so well that they
just come out like i think kubrick said
the actors should know their lines so
well that they can't say them wrong
and i think that there's a lot to that
so so yeah i
put a lot of effort into knowing my
lines so i just can press a button it
just comes out
and so then i can start thinking about
all the things
not the words but all the things that
i'm thinking
why i'm saying the words you know what i
mean yeah i absolutely
it's so you can sort of like talk to
someone and look at something and grab
something and like
open a book and like do things and not
think of your lines and that's what
people do i'm like looking at something
i'm like
yeah so james and i'm drinking my uh
club soda
and i just want to have a conversation
that's exactly why you want to know your
lines and you can always tell i'm
wondering when i can sneak another sip
of coffee
yeah i got my coffee over there and a
lot of times i'm looking over let me no
no i should keep talking right now
wait until michael's making an
appointment and you can see the people
struggling that are just like going i
just want to get i looked into the
mirror last night i went over my lines
and these are the lines and that's it
and uh please don't have me do anything
else and that's all you know whatever
do you what's the line that fans when
you go to these cons because i've seen
you at the cons and they love you and
you play music and you
all these things what's the the the
quote they always say
will you say this line is there a line
that that is your favorite or their
favorite that you go oh this one again i
have to say
like mine is i am the villain of the
story so what's yours
out for a walk [ __ ]
that's it i only have to say five words
out for a walk
[ __ ] yeah yeah but you said it a
certain way
yeah but buffy finds spike outside her
uh house
uh staring into the window she's like
spike what are you doing here
in five words or less and he's all
completely embarrassed
that he's been caught uh he's in love
with her she's not in love with him yet
and he's totally embarrassed and he's
like look out for a walk
[ __ ]
that's crazy it's a great line do you
remember uh working on smallville with
me
and tom yeah yeah what do you remember
about that experience because i remember
you know and tom loves you by the way he
every time we see you somewhere he's
like he's i like that guy i he's
the whole cast man that was such a great
experience man
um i remember being on set with you
and having publicity wanting to stoke a
competition between you and i
and the fact that you and i would not
have it and we would just not feed into
that at all and we was like no this is
cool guy man i can't wait to act with
him
it's going to be a lot of fun and they
kept asking me questions
like yeah don't don't you think you're
gonna get over on him on today aren't
you gonna
who's the better actor who's the bigger
badass i'm like i guess oh my god
you know um i remember
this i remember the humiliation of
acting with tom willie
um because we would do a lot of walking
talks and i'm not
i'm not tom welling tall so when you
have
you know the the close-up shot of both
of us
in the shot if you want me in the shot
you have to put me up on apple boxes
and so when we're walking they would
have to like tape
15 to 50 apple boxes together in a big
ramp uh to you know
how tall are you five nine it's it's a
reasonable height
but he's six five he's six five i had to
deal with it too and i was lex luthor
and i was like looking up at him going
listen to me [ __ ]
you know it's like jesus you know but uh
apple box occasionally i would you know
i'd say hey guys i want an apple box and
the director go
what are you suddenly going to be taller
than tom i'm like all right what's the
difference
half an apple um well dude you know and
i know that you love playing music i
know that you had a band i knew you
broke up i know you got back together
and and
did some things i i had a band too and
it's it's sort of like every actor has a
band it's like
i just i know what it is is i like
[ __ ] i love music you love music so
yeah
having a band is not easy now you hear
all these stories when bands break
up and you're like what the [ __ ] they
can't get along they have these hits
they do this
there's a little band that nobody knows
and we can't get it together you know
yeah was it was it tough i think that
you're dealing with people's inner child
when you're dealing with artists uh a
lot of us
a lot of artists you know we we say that
we feel whole
when we're doing our art and that's
because our inner child
feels only feels comfortable enough to
come out into the sunshine
when there's a structure in the safety
and art provides i think that
for me anyway that structure and that
safety and i've noticed it
you know it's the same thing you know
rehearsing a play or any
any mass artistic endeavor and people
come in with ideas and they come up with
instincts and
they're they're basically sharing what
their inner child is wanting to show
and if if you disagree with it you're
basically telling your
the other person's inner child [ __ ] you
go back go back into the darkness and
and
uh and it can get really passionate all
right listen this is uh [ __ ] talking
with uh with uh with i guess it's [ __ ]
talking with james marshes but uh these
are patreon fans so this is
patreon this is their fans they have
questions they're
they're my patrons they're awesome and
they have some questions so this is
spitfire so you go
you go boom you answer them you don't
you know anna a if you could add or
change one thing about spike's character
what would it be
not a goddamn thing really not one thing
not a goddamn
how about the color of his hair no look
[ __ ] fabulous you kidding me
you did look fabulous gorgeous but you
suffered my god you suffered man you
suffered for art
but i look good and in los angeles it's
better to look good than to feel good
fernando said that on saturday night
live billy crystal's kid she goes you
know my daddy always told me so fernando
don't be a schnook it's not how you feel
it's how
you look he loves them
look you look absolutely judith d dear
james what did you think of this series
finale of angel i thought it was
beautiful and epic i
just uh just like buffies yeah that
would be the one thing i would change
about
about angel they dumped ice water on us
for for 18 hours because it all
we they didn't we got cancelled by
surprise so they couldn't
save back enough money uh to make a big
epic ending so they just
they just dumped huge water on us and
they forgot to park the water truck in
the sun so the water was ice cold
and i was already coughing up blood i
was so sick by the end of that
season and they were just frozen i bet
boreanaz lost his [ __ ]
no man we muscled up none of us actually
bitched about it but but
we were muttering that's because i
wasn't there you know because you can
see your breath and then like an action
leanne p i mean you just said this any
fun cool uh behind-the-scene moments
from smallville that you would like to
share but i mean
you know yeah i remember coming on the
set
uh finding out that the the stunt man
who was the head of the department and
also doubled tom had just taken an
18-foot
fall that his wire yeah everybody
thought he was dead
he fell and he wasn't all his but they
said his body the sound it made was
they thought he was dead somehow he
rehabilitated and and
and he's fine i mean obviously
you know but i don't know how he lived
was it 25 feet wasn't it
yeah it was insane and like it wasn't
the first time like that that kind of
thing that happened over on buffy that's
like it's actually dangerous stunts are
actually dangerous
and that was that was the day that i
they were gonna put me in a big um
mechanical arm to fly me like like uh
uh superman just punched me and then i
have to go twirling through
space or whatever right and so they had
to like manipulate me and
i was just like really today
oh my god okay you know uh
todd do you have a favorite show that
you'd love to have a guest role in
dark dude but here's the thing
the first season was probably the best
show i've seen in years
right unbelievable that show and the
thing is that they
this is supposed to be rapid fire i'm
incapable of rapid fire
both of us apologize but i i always
imagine the director on dark
because it gives the same note every
take i imagine
stop acting less please less
less less because the actors is so good
because the actors are doing
nothing yeah right it's so simple and
it's so effective what if we just did
this interview like nothing like
so um i don't know he's just are you
happy uh all right lisa lisa h is your
side project
vidiot's done you and mark were just
hilarious in that definitely
a comedy duo oh man yeah
mark became a father and he has he has
now got a real job so he's not coming
out with
me to um to conventions which is where
we filmed
the idiots i'm afraid so right now it's
it's uh if we can figure out a way
to to keep it going we will but for now
it's
it's iced brian h how did you get the
gig to do the audiobooks for the dresden
files and who's your favorite character
to read
i don't know why they chose me i i have
no clue but jim
butcher who writes the dresden files
they asked him who he wanted they said
me
i remember uh thinking that it would be
an easy job and finding very quickly
that it was a very difficult job have
you ever done a book on tapeworm
um yeah it's a lot it's a lot of work
it's a lot right
i remember i came back from lunch and
the director was surprised he's like you
tv
actors you usually go out to for lunch
you don't come back so good for you
at least you're doing that my
my favorite character is bob the scowl
because he's got a very interesting
accent
and he's um a disembodied uh spirit
that lives in a skull and um he can't
get out
and he's horny all the time so he's a
pervert so he's always talking about
trying to get pornography into the into
the skull
and uh no one will give it to him you
are damn good with these accents it's
unbelievable
it's so funny too when you when they
read i get nervous because like you know
you tell me to read something like
i'll read these questions i don't i
don't think about it then you say all
right read and you're like
right before they are rolling and
they're like ready
like you got to get started like
the first day was tough the first day
the first time was yeah okay thomas t
i met you at a comic-con my wife and i
were dressed as lois and clark and you
took a video of us at his table
at your table i'm curious what's the
best cosplay you've seen
and taken a video of
what's the best i mean really do you
just videotape other cosplay people
yeah yeah uh it's the thing i do if you
if you're dressed
in cosplay of any uh any show that i've
done
uh then i just take you a quick video
where you know i would be like
hi i'm james and i'm spike and that's it
that's all you gotta do
and then i just put those together into
a short film
uh and then have an audience clapping at
the end
and then just put that on social media
after the con and what's the best one
uh there was a zamasu um from dragon
ball super
uh i played zamasu in dragon ball super
uh and it's a really wild character he's
a god he's got you know enormous hair
and you know big shoulders and
everything and someone someone just
added down to a t
yeah i can appreciate that i think you
and i are a lot alike in terms of like
the cons
to me are sort of they feel like home in
a way they just feel like
uh you know i love getting toys and
posters and things and
uh i just love it there i feel at home i
went to those before i became anything
anyone i went to horror conventions and
uh me too yeah i looked at those dressed
as spock
really pointed ears i had the tricorder
i had the tunic i had everything in a
big blonde afro because i could not
control my hair when i was 13 years old
can you do a spock accent i don't think
he has one
i don't i can go like that but doesn't
yeah the original leonard nimoy
yeah he just he just yeah i don't know
i'm not really a mimic
to tell you the truth it's hard for me
to turn to another person that's a deep
voice
i can do accents but it's a different
thing what's the one impression you go
to can you do one impression
of someone no
see that's the thing you could soon as
i'm walking around my house you're gonna
be like i should have done that
uh i don't nothing comes to mind because
you do so many accents you think there's
the
you know if you just you probably do
what's his name picard you could
probably if you listen to him do picard
data yeah make it so
no but i'm just doing a plummy accent
that's all i'm doing it's not
that's not steward but it's in essence
of stuart
patrick stewart yeah okay
what was wrong with that okay i remember
i i can't do james mason but remember
james mason
yeah yeah he had something i can't do it
but i know there's this one like
us hello
he would do that hello jim it's time to
go now
or something like that right james mason
salem's lot
put it down give it to the monster
something i forgot what it was dude this
has been so fun i'm glad we finally got
to do this we've talked about it
um and i know you're busy i know you got
a family and
it's just like i'm glad you opened up
and you were able to uh hang out with me
totally man i've been looking forward to
this ever since you asked me for the
last week and a half i've been telling
everybody i'm i'm on rosin bob's podcast
what's next i know everybody's sort of
like you know i don't know what's next
because we're kind of like
you can't really act you can't do um you
know are you doing anything
i'm waiting uh we just finished a pitch
to dc
for an idea for a comic book series uh
that i've had for
a number of years that i probably
shouldn't talk about but it's super
freaking awesome
and uh we've pitched it and there uh our
contact to dc is gonna
is gonna send our pitch up to up the
ladder and see if we get a comic book
uh and we're just waiting on that i'm
hoping because it's the perfect thing to
do during a lockdown
is right oh yeah and then i just
finished the next dresden file book
um uh called peace talks
uh and that'll be coming out in a few
weeks i think
so you just set up your quarter at home
and do it there no
we actually i went to the studio well
think about it it's probably you in a
room that's it
exactly yeah i mean you go and wipe down
the room and and
make sure no one comes in adjust your
own mic and you're fine would you ever
do a buffy reunion
yeah uh i told joss during angel that
that uh if he
if he called me for anything whether
it's one line or 50 i'd come one no
matter where i was in the world but if
you wanted to
film me doing spike he had seven years
because i'm aging and spike's a vampire
and i i don't want to play an aged spike
you know like i would just spike now be
like what happened to spike he looks
like [ __ ] uh have you seen like once
upon a time in hollywood
they you young i almost said euthanized
because they young animized uh you can
look younger
and you look good too what are you
talking your skin looks good at least
from my
vantage point i mean what are you
talking about
you're younger than me [ __ ] the face
changes i don't know
uh yes if there was a way or if spike
was
always in vampire phase then that might
work
so sure you know um yeah uh yeah man if
josh wanted me to work again
uh i would just i just really want to
protect
that idea that he's he's a vampire he
doesn't age that's one of the
core things about being a vampire do you
still talk to him
what's that do you still talk to joss or
sarah or any of those
anybody um yeah you know i email sarah
once a while we brag about our kids
i think my kids are more impressive so
in my mind i i beat her every single
time because her kids are much younger
than mine
right um joss no i saw him uh last time
i saw joss was uh
uh during the entertainment weekly photo
shoot where we were
it was the 20th year anniversary or
whatever and we did a photo shoot and i
got to talk with him a bit
you know and i found he was the same
josh like i thought maybe he'd have
changed after avengers and everything
like he'd be like
mr important guy and he was the same
joss he was racked by self-doubt
just like always i love that guy james
thanks for doing this and uh
appreciating best luck what's your
handle by the way your your twitter and
instagrams people follow you
uh james marksters of as an official but
just
off is on twitter uh and then the
official james marshall's
facebook page well i'd love to do this
again i'd love to when this is over go
have a beard something
i would love it talk about the old days
we're getting to that age where i'm like
well what you're like 10 years younger
than me aren't you
uh no i'm 58. what yeah you're older
than me
am i okay i didn't know you were older
i thought you were younger than me i
swear to god
mike i have this light that my wife gave
me look at that you know i have a light
in there i have light in the other room
too
hey put this light right in your face
but you look good here i'll turn it off
for you
oh my gosh phil looked great you know
there was a moment i think i've talked
about this but um i remember
one day i was just it's 5 a.m and i'm in
the makeup trailer and
i'm shaving my face with an electric
razor and the makeup artist natalie goes
uh michael that's tom's razor and i go
oh no wonder i was feeling so gorgeous
for a second
and then i went back to mild rays and i
was like oh the horror
the horror i'm hideous
i think i posted that somewhere dude i
love you thank you again and uh
thank you please say thanks to your wife
for letting uh you use her phone
she saved the whole deal she did man
this would have been
shitty i'll cook for it tonight thanks
for allowing me to be inside of you
that's what i say
hey all right shut up god damn it
all right well thank you james marsters
that uh
i enjoyed that i had never really talked
to him that much because he was uh on
smallville with me and we see each other
at conventions but it's like hey dude
and i don't i don't remember really
having in-depth conversations with him
um before today and uh
it just was um i just have a brand new
respect it's amazing when you just take
a minute to get to know someone
you could learn so much and i've done
that with so many guests where i'm like
wow i like this person
that's why you shouldn't judge others
you shouldn't say oh i heard that guy's
an [ __ ] so he must be an [ __ ]
no i heard she's a [ __ ] why because
someone heard that you heard that heard
that she was a [ __ ]
try to be open-minded man i do it i'm i
can judge man i am mike
judge i am judge judy i am judy dench
judge that didn't make sense uh let me
just to read uh by the way i just want
to say a big shout out to all the
patrons who support this podcast i love
you more than you know
thank you anybody who wants to join
patreon check it out
uh go to the patreon app and you can
join there's so many cool tiers and
communities and i do
uh youtube lives for everyone uh where i
play music and they recommend songs and
you know you just get discounts on stuff
and um
just just so much good stuff there's so
much just look at the tiers and maybe
you want to join if not thank you for
just listening and
subscribing uh please please look at the
uh you know please follow
us and um inside you at insideypodcast
instagram facebook at insideapod on
um twitter and uh subscribe on youtube
that's a big one too we're growing
we started like 18 000 i think we have
over 50 000 subscribers now or something
like that but
uh please watch and listen uh if you
could do both that'd be amazing wow
listen and watch
i would owe you do you understand me
here's a uh
a fan letter i won't read the whole
thing this is some candy
miss candy she uh she is so supportive
and loving
and it seems like everything i do it's
just it's just like a
it's just she's a wonderful person and
she has a huge heart and i just i really
appreciate her and i want to read
something that she said
love your podcast it's so inspiring and
holds my
interest great therapy this is one of
the best
podcasts i have ever listened to it can
relate to most of the inspiring stories
your guests talk about
i love that you and your guests are so
honest and open about their lives and
issues and can talk about it it's hard
to find people that are
true to themselves and can be honest and
are not
fake um
you know thank you
um candy you're so
you're so amazing and it's funny because
i didn't even know this was your letter
i just
started looking i go wow this is some
candy and um
candy is a cancer and domestic violence
survivor
and uh she has a heart of gold
a heart of gold and that's what it's
like you know that's what it is that's
what it's about
is what i'm trying to say um
so thank you candy thank you for writing
in and um
it means a lot uh here's another one
michael thank you for creating both your
podcast well one is gone now but i still
have the inside e podcast so thank you
this is from uh valerie
it seems when i listen to each one that
something in it
is something i needed to hear at that
moment you see i don't
love myself anymore
probably because the last man i gave
love to
died by suicide in june
and i'm struggling every day to know why
i was not enough for him to overcome his
pain
and stay
i'm learning i couldn't have stopped him
but my heart hasn't caught up
anyway thanks michael valerie that's
tremendously sad and
you know uh i think if you look
if you look at history and you look at
people that have committed suicide
you know i probably there's probably not
one person who hasn't said
i wish i could have i that's that's
something that
is gonna happen with any kind of death
for the most part i mean
obviously suicide you feel you know uh
like oh my god i didn't know they were
that sad i didn't know this i
i think um when you're in a certain
state of mind
like he was maybe and again i'm not dr
rosenbaum i'm just kind of from friends
and from people i've known that
committed suicide and people have
experienced it and had loved ones that
you know i
just feel like when they're in that
mindset there's nothing anybody
could have said or could have done
and uh you know like the robin williams
thing
you know everybody's like what what why
why would he do
he was in pain and you know things were
going on in his mind that
no one could understand except him i
assume
so i don't valerie don't you don't you
get down on what you could have done or
um you'll find love again and you
deserve it
we all deserve it and um
and i'm sorry i really am sorry
it's a it's a terrible thing when
someone passes especially in that manner
so uh i could just say uh you know i
love you
val and i'm sure you know a lot of
people love you and care about you so
stay positive and
you know be healthy you know um
he didn't want to be here obviously for
some reason so you um
why don't you live the life that you
wish he could have had
be as happy as you can be as present as
you can
and um i don't know probably spitballing
here but i'm i'm just trying to speak
from the heart
uh big shout outs uh you know uh first
of all uh obviously
uh i i just did the uh
galaxy con virtual thing on sunday it
was a it was fantastic a lot of fun
zooms with fans and i'm doing another
one for informa
so if you want to do zooms and
autographs all that stuff we're doing a
virtual one smallville informa
july 30th or 27th
look online i'll post something but
informa
um again new uh inside of you masks and
mugs uh
they're online at the inside of your
store
uh join patreon if you so desire uh
inside of your podcast on patreon and
where have all the good horror movies
gone on patreon
it's always nice to see new people and i
like to message them and say welcome
and it is me i do not allow bryce to
make comments unless someone's looking
at something that's wrong with their
site so it is me i always say rosie or
rosenbaum but you know it's me by the
way i speak no one speaks like me like
an idiot
okay here are the uh shout outs nancy d
mary b i know all these names i mean i
could say their
last names i'm not going to nancy d mary
b leah s tricia f
sarah v yukiko jill e brian h lauren g
nico p barry i angelina g
jerry w kevin r emily k bobby robert to
be
jason w kristen k i always think kristen
crook but i know it's the other kristen
hi kristen
amelia oh oh oh oh amelia
sorry alison l jason d raj
joshua d emily s cjp samantha m hamza b
jennifer ann stacy b carly t reem
jennifer s janelle b tabitha 272
kimberly e melissa c mike e jake m
marisa
n hi judith d ramirez beth b
chris f sarah f chad w leanne p we're
almost done
darla w jackie p rodrigo s
rachel c rey rey rey
maya p morgan d demario jennifer c
marty s marias tiffany l
kendrick f ashley e kelly w sigourney p
tom t matt w belinda
n benjamin r those are the top tier
patrons
they are amazing they support the
podcast they keep it going
uh if you know you want to help out sure
i'm gonna
you know i'm gonna yell at you i'm gonna
give you love
man i'm gonna give you some love thank
you for listening again make sure you
subscribe email all your friends make
sure they subscribe and
uh write reviews um if i don't get back
to you it takes a couple months for the
uh hello at insideyoupodcast.com if you
leave a message it could take time
i can't do this many things at the same
time brian's not here
i'm missing i don't have my wonderful
jessica
um who you've heard about my assistant
she's wonderful
she's uh she's not with me anymore but
we're on great terms it wasn't like that
and i love her and hi look come on oh
special guest
come here come on come on
look at this special guest here i've got
my doggy blanche as i end the show
you came in at the right time didn't you
she's a good girl
and she smells good breathe in the
microphone
hear that that's her nose uh i love you
all thank you all for allowing me to be
inside of you today
and um another big shout out to my
patrons
on the horror where i have all the
horror movies good harmony is gone
inside of you patreon
and uh bryce and uh ryan i love you
and uh i wish everybody the best have a
great freaking week man
and stay safe stay healthy do something
positive
in my uh what is a blanche
um thank you can you stop i love you um
foodonfoot.org uh ronald mcdonald house
of los angeles
echoes of hope uh shout out to all my
charities i love you guys thank you
[Music]